uh Apple has mostly stopped advertising
on Twitter do they hate free speech in
America
what's going on here Tim Cook Tim Cook
of course is the CEO of Apple and then
Jonathan Chait he wrote try posting more
conspiracy theories and white
supremacist memes that ought to bring
them back Elon Musk has not posted any
white supremacist memes this is complete
nonsense and the idea that somehow
Twitter can't be a place where people
share conspiracy theories well I don't
know Donald Trump very fine people on
both sides Brett Kavanaugh is a serial
rapist uh you know all the stuff right
we could we could literally just go
through these all day the Jesse smalat
hoax he's exposing the power structure
the cultural norms of corporate press
and and all of the the journalistic
outlets he's he's exposing them for what
they are they are tyrants they are the
machine and they're losing a bit of
control